the model announced tonight by open AI
called 03 could well be the final
reputation the artificial intelligence
was hitting a wall open AI it seems have
not so much as surmounted that wall they
have supplied evidence that the wall did
not in fact exist the real news of
tonight isn't for me the 03 just crushed
benchmarks designed to stand for decades
it's that open AI have shown that
anything you can Benchmark the O Series
of models can eventually beat let me
invite you to think of any challenge if
that challenge is ultimately susceptible
to reasoning and if the reasoning steps
are represented anywhere in the training
data the O Series of models will
eventually Crush that challenge yes it
might have cost 03 or open AI 350 Grand
in thinking time to beat some of these
benchmarks but costs alone will not hold
the tide at Bay for long yes I'll give
the caveats I always do and there are
quite a few but I must admit and I will
admit that this is a Monumental day in
Ai and pretty much everyone listening
should adjust their timelines before we
get to the absolutely crazy benchmark
scores what actually is 03 what did they
do well I've given more detail on the 0
series of models in previous videos on
this channel but let me give you a
30second summary I AI get the base model
to generate hundreds or potentially
thousands of candidate Solutions
following long chains of thought to get
to an answer a verifier model likely
based on the same base model then
reviews those answers and ranks them
looking for classic calculation mistakes
or reasoning mistakes that verifier
model of course is trained on thousands
of correct reasoning steps but here's
the kicker in scientific domains like
mathematics and coding you can know what
the correct answer is so when the system
generates a correct set of reasoning
steps steps that led to the correct
verified answer then the model as a
whole can be fine-tuned on those correct
steps this fundamentally shifts us from
predicting the next word to predicting
the series of tokens that will lead to
an objectively correct answer that
fine-tuning on just the correct answers
can be classed as reinforcement learning
so what then is 03 well more of the same
as one researcher at open aai told us
tonight 03 is powered by further scaling
up reinforcement learning Beyond 01 no
special ingredient added to 01 it seems
no secret Source no wall and that's why
I said in the intro if you can Benchmark
it the O Series of models can eventually
beat it what I don't want to imply
though is that this leap forward with 03
was entirely predictable yes I talked
about AI being on an exponential in my
first video of this year and I even
referenced verifiers and inference time
compute that's the fancy term for
thinking longer and generating more
candidate Solutions but I am in pretty
good company in not predicting this much
of a leap this soon let's briefly start
with Frontier Math and how did O3 do
this is considered today the toughest
mathematical Benchmark out there this is
a data set that consists of Novel
unpublished and also very hard extremely
hard yeah very very hard problems even
turn houses you know it would take
professional mathematicians hours or
even days to solve one of these problems
and today all offerings out there have
less than 2% accuracy on this Benchmark
and we're seeing with 03 in aggressive
test time settings we're able to get
over
25% yeah they didn't say this in the
announcement tonight but the darker part
of the bar the smaller part is the model
getting it right with only one attempt
the lighter part of the bar is when the
model gave lots of different solutions
but the one that came up the most most
often the consensus answer was the
correct answer we'll get to time and
cost in a moment but those details aside
the achievement of 25% is Monumental
here's what Terren to said at the
beginning of November these questions
are extremely challenging he's arguably
the smartest guy in the world by the way
I think that in the near term basically
the only way to solve them short of
having a real domain expert in the area
is by a combination of a semi-expert
like a grad student in a related field
pair with some combination of a modern
Ai and lots of other algebra packages
given that 03 doesn't rely on algebra
packages he's basically saying that O3
must be a real domain expert in
mathematics summing up Terren to said
that this Benchmark would resist AIS for
several years at least Sam Orman seem to
imply that they were releasing the full
03 perhaps in February or at least the
first quarter of next year and that
implies to me at least that they didn't
just bust every single GPU on the planet
to get this score but could never serve
it realistically to the public or to
phrase things another way we are not at
the limits of the compute we even have
available today the Next Generation 04
could be with us by quarter 2 of next
year 05 by quarter 3 here's what another
top open AI researcher said' 03 is very
performant more importantly progress
from 01 to03 was only 3 months which
shows how fast progress will be in the
new paradigm of reinforcement learning
on Chain of Thought to scale influence
compute way faster than the pre-training
Paradigm of a new model every 1 to two
years we may never get GPT 5 but get AGI
anyway of course safety testing May well
end up delaying the release to the
public of these new generations of
models and so there might end up being
an increasingly wide gap between what
the frontier Labs have available to use
themselves and what the public has what
about Google proof graduate level
science questions and as one openai
researcher put it take a moment of
silence for that Benchmark it was born
in November of 2023 and died just a year
later why rip GP QA well 03 gets
87.7% benchmarks are being crushed
almost as quickly as they can be created
then there's competitive coding where 03
establishes itself as the
175th highest scoring Global competitor
better at this coding competition than
99.95% of humans now you might say
that's competition coding that's not
real software engineering but then we
had sbench verified that Benchmark tests
real issues faced by real software
Engineers the verified part refers to
the fact that the Benchmark was combed
for only genuine questions with real
clear answers Claude 3.5 Sonic gets 49%
71.7% as foreseen you could argue by the
CEO of anthropic the creators of Claude
um the latest model we released Sonet
3.5 the new updated version it gets
something like 50% on sbench and sbench
is an example of a bunch of professional
real world software engineering tasks at
the beginning of the year I think the
state-of-the-art was three or 4% so in
10 months we've gone from 3% to 50% on
this task and I think in another year
we'll probably be at 90% I mean I don't
know but might might even be might even
be less than that before you ask by the
way yes these were unseen programming
competitions this isn't data
contamination again if you can Benchmark
it the O Series of models will
eventually or imminently Beat It
interestingly if you were following the
channel closely you might have guessed
that this was coming in code forces as
of this time last year Google produced
Alpha code 2 which in certain parts of
the code forces competition outperformed
99.5% of competition participants and
they went on prophetically we find that
performance increases roughly log
linearly with more samples yes of course
I'm going to get to Arc AGI but I just
want to throw in my first quick caveat
what happens if you can't Benchmark it
or at least it's harder to Benchmark or
the field isn't as susceptible to
reasoning steps how about personal
writing for example well as open AI
admitted back in September the O Series
of models starting with o1 VI is not
preferred on some natural language tasks
suggesting that is not well suited for
all use cases again then think of a task
is there an objectively correct answer
to that task the O Series will likely
soon beat it as O3 proof tonight that's
regardless of how difficult that task is
is the correctness of the answer or the
quality of the output more a matter of
taste however well that might take
longer to be what about core reasoning
though out of distribution
generalization what I started this
channel to cover back at the beginning
of last year forgetting about cost or
latency for a moment what we all want to
know is how intrinsically intelligent
are these models that will dictate
everything else and I will raise that
question through three examples to end
the video the first is compositionality
which came in a famous paper in nature
published last year essentially you test
models by making up a language full of
con Concepts like between or double or
colors and see if they can compose those
Concepts into a correct answer the
concepts are abstract enough that they
would of course never have been seen in
the training data the original GPT 4
flopped hard at this challenge in the
paper in nature and 01 PR mode gets
close but still can't do it after
thinking for 9 minutes it successfully
translates who as double but doesn't
quite understand Moro it thinks it's
something about symmetry but doesn't
grasp that it means between will 03
master compositionality I can't answer
that question because I can't yet test
it next is of course my own Benchmark
called Simple bench this video was
originally meant to be a summary of the
12 days I was going to show off VO2 and
talk about Gemini 2.0 flash thinking
experimental from Google the thinking
this time invisible chains of thought is
reminiscent then of the O Series of
models on the three runs we've done so
far it scores around 25% which is great
for such a small model as flash but
isn't quite as good as even their own
model Gemini experimental 126 for this
particular day of shipus we are though
putting Google to one side because open
AI have produced 03 so here's what I'm
looking out for in 03 to see whether it
would crush simple bench essentially it
needs to master spatial reasoning now
you can pause and read the question
yourself but I helpfully supplied 01
prom mode with this visual as well and
without even reading the question what
would you say would happen to this glove
if it fell off of the bike and let's say
I also supplied you with the speed of
the river well you might well say to me
thanks for all of those details but
honestly the glove is just going to fall
onto the road 01 doesn't even consider
that possibility and never does because
spatial data isn't really in its
training data nor is sophisticated
social reasoning data wait let me caveat
that of course we don't know what is in
the training data I just suspect it's
not in the training data of 01 at least
likely not in 03 but we don't know is
the base model for 03 oion or what would
have been GPT 4.5 GPT 5 open AI never
mentioned a shift in what the base model
was but they haven't denied it either
someone could make the argument that 03
is so good at something like physics
that it can Intuit it for itself what
would happen in spatial reasoning
scenarios maybe but we'd have to test it
what I do have to remind myself though
with simple bench and spatial reasoning
more generally is it doesn't strike me
perhaps as a fundamental limitation for
the model going forward as I said right
in the start of the intro to this video
open AI have fundamentally with 03
demonstrated the extent of a
generalizable approach to solving things
in other words with enough spatial
reasoning data and good spatial
reasoning benchmarks and some more of
that scaled up reinforcement learning I
think models would get great at this too
and frankly even if benchmarks like
simple bench Can last a little bit
longer because of a parity of spatial
reasoning data or text-based spatial
reasoning data not being enough you have
simulators like genesis that can model
physics and give models like O3 almost
infinite training data of lifelike
simulations you could almost imagine 03
404 being unsure of an answer spinning
up a simulation spotting what would
happen and then outputting the answer
and now at last what about Ark AGI I
made an entire video not that long ago
about how this particular challenge
created by France Chalet was a necessary
but not sufficient condition for AGI the
reason why 03 beating this Benchmark is
so significant is because each example
is supposed to be a novel test a
challenge in other words that's
deliberately designed not to be in any
training data past or present beating it
therefore has to involve at least a
certain level of reasoning in case
you're wondering by the way I think
reasoning is actually a spectrum I
Define it as deriving efficient
functions and composite functions llms
therefore always have done a form of
reasoning it's just that their functions
that they derive are not particularly
efficient more like convoluted
interpolations humans tend to spot
things quicker have more meta rules of
thumb and with these more meta rules of
thumb we can generalize better and solve
challenges that we haven't seen before
more efficiently hence why many humans
can see what has occurred to get from
input one to Output one input two to
Output two GPT 4 couldn't and even 01
couldn't really and for these specific
examples even 03 can't yes it might
surprise you there are still questions
that aren't crazy hard the 03 Can't Get
Right nevertheless 03 when given maximal
compute what I've calculated at being
350 Grand worth gets 88% and here's what
the author of that Benchmark said this
isn't just Brute Force yes it's very
expensive but these capabilities are new
territory and they demand serious
scientific attention we believe he said
said it represents a significant
breakthrough in getting AI to adapt to
novel tasks reinforced again and again
with those chains of thought or
reasoning steps that led it to correct
answers 03 has gotten pretty good at
deriving efficient functions in other
words it reasons pretty well now Chalet
has often mentioned in the past that
many of his smart friends scored around
98% in AR AGI but a fairly recent paper
from September showed that that when an
exhaustive study was done on average
human performance it was
64.2% on the public evaluation set
Chalet himself predicted 2 and a half
years ago that there wouldn't be a quote
pure Transformer based model that gets
greater than 50% on previously unseen
Arc tasks within a time limit of 5 years
again I want to give you a couple of
quick caveats before we get to his
assessment of whether o03 is Agi one
open AI researcher admitted that it took
16 hours to get 03 to get
87.5% with an increase rate of 3.5% an
hour to get to solved and another caveat
this time from his public statement on
03 open aai apparently requested that
they didn't publish the high compute
costs involved in getting that high
score but they kind of did anyway saying
the amount of compute was roughly 172 X
the low compute configuration if the low
compute high efficiency retail cost was
$22,000 by my calculation that's around
$350 Grand to get the
87.5% if your day job is solving Arc AGI
challenges and you're paid less than 350
Grand a year you're safe just for now
and of course if you're crazy worried by
cost there's always 03 mini which gets
close to the performance of 03 for a
fraction of the cost but more seriously
he said later in the statement but cost
performance will likely improve quite
dramatically over the next few months
and years so you should plan for these
capabilities to become competitive with
human work within a fairly short
timeline the challenge was always to get
models to reason the costs and latency
came second those can drop later with
more gpus More's law and algorithmic
efficiency it's the crushing of these
challenges that was the hard part cost
is not a barrier that's going to last
long now Chalet does go on to say that
03 still fails on some very easy tasks
and you might argue that that Arc
challenge I showed just earlier was such
an example the blocks move essentially
in the direction of the lines that
protrude out of them and he mentions
that he's crafting a so-called Ark AGI 2
Benchmark that he thinks will still pose
a significant challenge to o03
potentially reducing its score to under
30% sounds like he's almost already
tested it he goes on even at at high
compute while a smart human would still
be able to score over 95% with no
training notice that smart human rather
than average human though and also it's
kind of like 03 is under 30% but what
about 04 05 what if even 06 is released
before the end of 2025 that's maybe why
Mike nup the funer of the arc $1 million
prize says we want AGI benchmarks that
can endure many years I do not expect V2
will and so cryptically he says we're
also starting turning attention to V3
which will be very different that sets
up the crucial definition then of what
counts as AGI is it still not AGI as
long as there's any Benchmark that the
average human can outperform a model at
Chet's position at least as of tonight
is that he doesn't believe that o03 is
AI the reason because it's still
feasible to create unsaturated not
crushed interesting benchmarks that are
easy for humans yet impossible for AI
without involving specialist knowledge
in some we will have AGI when creating
such evals becomes outright impossible
the question is is that a fair marker
does it have to be impossible to create
such a benchmark one that humans can
beat easily yet is impossible for AI or
should the definition of AGI be when
it's harder to create a benchmark that's
easier for humans than it is for AI in a
way that seems like a fairer definition
such that there isn't just a single
Benchmark out there that's holding out
and the rest have fallen and we're still
saying not AGI that of course leaves the
question of is it harder to create a
benchmark that O3 can't solve and yet
it's easy for humans do we consider
different modalities can it spot the
lack of realism in certain AI generated
videos what kind of benchmarks are
allowed or are not allowed what about
benchmarks where we factor in how
quickly challenges are solved I alas
can't provide a satisfying answer for
those of you who want a simple yes no
AGI or not what I can do though is shine
a light on the significance of this
achievement again it's not about
particular benchmarks it's about an
approach that can be used again and
again on whatever Benchmark you create
and to whatever scale you can pay for
it's almost like they've shown that they
can defeat the very concept of a
benchmark yes of course I read the paper
released tonight by open AI on
deliberative alignment essentially they
use these same reasoning techniques to
get the models to be great at refusing
harmful requests while also not over
refusing innocent ones know Brown who is
one of the research leads 401 said that
Frontier math result actually had safety
implications he said even if llms are
dumb in some ways and of course I can't
yet test o03 on simple bench nor even 01
they haven't yet given me API access he
went on saturating evals like Frontier
math suggests AI is surpassing top human
intelligence in certain domains the
first implication of that he said is
that we may see a broad acceleration in
scientific research but then he went on
this also means that AI safety topics
like scalable oversight May soon stop
being hypothetical research in these
domains needs to be a priority for the
field scalable oversight in a ridiculous
nutshell is answering the question of
how essentially a dumber model or a
human can still have oversight over a
smarter model this then is one of the
co-creators of 03 saying we really need
to start focusing on safety it's perhaps
then more credible when open AI
researchers like John hman say this when
Sam and as researchers say AGI is coming
we aren't doing it to sell you Kool-Aid
a $2,000 subscription or to trick you to
invest in our next round it's actually
coming whatever you've made of o03
tonight let me know in the comments
personally can't wait to test it this
has been a big night in Ai and thank you
so much for joining me on it as always
would love to see you over on patreon
where I'll be continuing the discussion
and actually fairly soon releasing a
mini documentary on the Fateful year
2015 when open AI started but regardless
wherever you are have a wonderful day